[Music]
is it really a bummer that we're getting
Dumber a new study published in the
scientific journal intelligence suggests
that for the first time in 100 years the
average American's IQ is declining which
was greeted as good news in the journal
stupidity
I thought it was better when I saw it
this morning this reverses a trend that
saw average IQ jump three to five points
every decade since the 1930s so let me
say that be the first to say it nice job
Kardashians
the age group showing the steepest IQ
decline 18 to 22 year olds a group
scientist called girlfriends of DiCaprio
researchers theorize that quote either
the caliber of education is decreased
and or there has been a shift in the
perceived value of certain cognitive
skills and it's further proof that IQs
have declined I'm not even sure what the
hell that means
but whatever the reason this study could
be devastating for students self-esteem
unless they're very attractive then call
me students a pervert would say
all right Tyrus what do you think is
causing this decline
stupid ass parents yeah I mean that's
just we've all gotten stupid and lazy
you don't you let the you let the tablet
raise the child you don't have real life
lessons then you send them out in the
real world and if they don't like
something they get a safe space to hide
in or if a teacher says something they
don't like the teacher goes away so of
course we're all getting stupider the
reason and then those of us who don't
want to comply into that we get Dumber
hearing the conversations so then that's
why you see intelligent people with
headphones on all the time just trying
to survive try to have my headphones on
in the airplane I'd be drooling on
myself and eating human flesh by the
time I get here
I mean let's be honest when America
stops to watch reality TV we're stupid
like who enjoys that
you're all getting
it's always kind of the same go outside
there's this thing called the sun
go out there and just wait something
will happen yes that is true yeah
especially in New York City you might
get a naked man masturbate on you if
that's your thing then go for it yeah
I'm gonna look for more Wilderness stuff
taste the butterfly watch the deer eat
some grass
well he is an anus actually are you
worried about the IQ decline yes I am
and actually they've got a series of
good points to make because education is
a fundamentally affected by poverty and
here are some facts that help us
understand this it won't take very long
and I'm doing this because I respect you
and I love you I'm really reading out
some actual facts okay I love you if it
gets boring you can obviously stop me
and we could perhaps wrestle that would
be a brief you gotta beat her first
I would prefer that order
I worked the wrong if I began wrestling
with Emily I might not get around to you
[Music]
prolong this yes for just another couple
of decades we're running out of time for
you guys he's waiting
okay so listen to this according to
Global citizen poverty is the main
barrier to education in the United
States I want to draw your Collective
attention to the pandemic I think we all
understand that during the pandemic
education declined now I can see that
Greg's only got a one minute break yeah
one minute to a commercial so go wrap
this up other panelist Russell huh I
have other panelists thanks for coming
now listen during that pandemic period
billionaires added five trillion to
their fortunes that means that during
the pandemic a new billionaire was
created every single day while extreme
poverty increased everywhere while small
businesses closed everywhere and I'm
going to say something on Fox News until
recently would not have been possible as
president Donald Trump's tax cuts help
billionaires pay less taxes than the
working class in 2018 for the first time
in American history the 400 wealthiest
people paid a lower tax rate than any
other group but check this out Fox News
viewers because you're going to like
this bit in October 2021 Democrats scale
back plans for a Crackdown on taxi in
Bow into an aggressive lobbying campaign
by the banking industry while Joe Biden
told Rich donors on the campaign trail
that nothing would fundamentally change
if he were elected president so like
some of the great points in your
monologue having that reference that I
was a bit like Rasputin although he was
a pretty crazy sexy guy like you made
the point that it's the two-party system
itself and in particular the manner in
which it is funded that prevents
meaningful change for ordinary people
and this education problem while the
jokes you made were about the culture
Kardashians Etc really education if the
state has a duty at all is the
cultivation of Young Americans it is the
protection of Young Americans this would
be my point Greg Gutfeld very good very
good
look at it
edit out
about the last two minutes of that
that was the best bit
let me tether it to some promo why not
watch Fox News and other Affiliated
stations within News International now
you can just use that there we go Emily
what to say make it fast yeah I
attribute it all actually at a screen
time and social media right kids kids
are giving these screen times your point
from a tiny age but three to five that's
affecting their complex uh memory it's
reflecting reading it's affecting their
their cerebral development as they get
older they have thinner cortexes from it
and we know that your brain if you are
physically hurt exhibits the same
reaction as when you are socially
shunned so you throw in social media you
throw in those the the prepubescent and
pubescent teenagers who are getting
ostracized and canceled and told to kill
themselves that to me is the erosion
literally of the brain and the
depressive results that happen from that
that's why the IQs are so low and in
addition to what you said but I feel
strongly that the social media the
screen time that advent is the immediate
decline of the IQ Cat last word yeah I
think some of it has to do with what we
were talking about in the last block
because binary thinking is the enemy of
critical thinking because you're saying
that there's only two options when
actually there are Limitless
possibilities and when you pick a side
you don't have to think because the
thinking is done for you you just my
side good other side bad and if your
side does bad stuff instead of
confronting it you just list off bad
stuff the other side did and how they're
worse and that also leads to corruption
in government which stops from any help
coming to the people as you mentioned
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else